the US Navy called off the search this
morning for three sailors missing in the
western Pacific they were on a cargo
plane that crashed on Wednesday trying
to reach an American aircraft carrier
south of Japan Ben Tracy is following
the story from Beijing Ben good morning
good morning so the Navy ended the
search at 10 a.m. local time and they
are now notifying the families of these
lost sailors in all there were 11
members of the Navy that were on board a
c2 cargo plane known as a greyhound
when it crashed in the Philippine Sea
Wednesday afternoon about 575 miles
southeast of Okinawa Japan eight of the
sailors were quickly rescued the plane
was on a routine run out to the USS
Ronald Reagan aircraft carrier which was
participating in joint naval exercises
with Japanese forces at the time during
a two-day search eight ships and three
helicopter squadrons cover nearly 1,000
square nautical miles of ocean searching
for the missing sailors but they were
not found these three deaths now add to
the 17 other members of the Navy's
seventh fleet who were killed during
collisions involving the USS Fitzgerald
and McCain earlier this year in both of
those incidents the ship's crew was
found to be at fault now the Navy is
investigating the cause of this latest
accident but they have acknowledged that
the high tempo of operations in the
Pacific has led to reduced safety
margins Tony Benn Traci forests in
Beijing been thank you very much